time to portions away Alex - please
stand my love me look at me look at me
yeah poor beast that's it thank you
after those two beef yes thank you
[ __ ] you know to take the hot plate
please Alex isn't communicating with me
or a sous-chef wing come on guys and
this complex dish needs perfect
coordination Alex look at me if we get a
little bit organized yeah so the beef
doesn't hang around too long the hostler
yeah it's got to go yes I can't sit here
too long don't work together a little
bit more yeah chef yeah so you putting
it on was taking about four or five
minutes but it's got to go we can't keep
it back too long yeah otherwise gonna be
cold radio God so his face Alex's food
looks amazing but he seems to be
struggling to cope in my kitchen without
his large team chickens start falling
over on the hot plate please okay fine
let's go take the [ __ ] pan away a
shot there as well stop and go you let's
go go go go yeah boo that's right I'll
be done yes Joe please
let's go tables - where's the sauce good
thank you
sauce pour the left-hand side my kitchen
here in 50 I've never had an accident
and today I'm not gonna have one yeah
let's go Jesus Christ
very nice hello speech room service
please
sever one place yep thank you
seeing this now